they're everyone today I'm going to talk
about how to hire the right person for
your business so tiring is one of the
most frustrating and challenging things
that you can do as an entrepreneur and
someone my mastermind group is going
through this challenge right now and he
posted that he did all the right things
right you put out the job posting and
people apply they did the interviewing
and he went through that entire process
and he hired the guy he thought was
going to be the guy for him and then it
didn't work out and now he's frustrated
he's wasted a lot of time he's got to go
back and do everything himself again and
he feels overwhelmed and Aaron is one of
those really tricky things as an
entrepreneur because you need to hire to
grow your business you can't do
everything yourself there's no way you
could do everything yourself if you want
to build something big but it's such a
frustrating and annoying experience for
a lot of people and sometimes when you
get the wrong person on board it just
makes you feel like I'm not doing this
again I'm just going to do it my way
I'll get it done I'll get it right and
and then that limits your growth and so
I believe that the hiring process is
broken have that number of different
videos on it but I don't do interviews I
don't do cover letters I don't do
resumes I think those are so easy to I
don't wanna say fake but so easy to make
make it look good and it has nothing to
do with their job performance right how
well somebody so this this mask remember
does a lot of repairing of farm
equipment right how well somebody can
write a cover letter or how well
somebody can do in the interview has
nothing to do with their abilities to
repair farm equipment and that's the
biggest challenge and so I believe that
that process is broken and i have my own
way that has helped me to bring on what
16 people now on my team super low
turnover for the most part everybody
loves what they're doing I think
everybody does but you know there's
always room to improve I guess and so
I'm going to share with you the four
things that I do one I always lead with
what I stand for and so encourage you to
lead with what you stand for league with
your one word Ollie would believe lead
with what is most important to you don't
just talk about you needing somebody to
help prepare farm equipment lead with
the core
that means the most to you because
that's going to do one of two things
it's going to push people away to say oh
believe that's so stupid I don't want to
this guy's ridiculous I don't want to be
a part of that company which is great
because I might have taken the time to
go through that hiring process with him
and only to find out that we're not
going to we're going to we're not going
to vibe together right if you don't like
believe you're probably not going to be
afraid of this YouTube channel you're
not telling her to be a great employee
at my business on the flip side seeing
the people who love what that stands for
who love what it means who loves the
mission of the business and so those are
the people that you want to attract
whereas now if all you're doing is
putting up a job posting saying hey we
we need something to help us repair farm
equipment there's no way to tell the
difference between your shop and the
next guy shop and the next guy shop and
so you could just going to get everybody
right and so you want to make it easy
for people to self eliminate by leading
with what you stand for number two is I
always guilt give some kind of skill
testing question in my job posting it'll
be one big long ugly disgusting
paragraph that is hard on the eyes hard
to read I do that a lot because one I am
not always the most detail-oriented
person and so I need people who work
with me to be detail-oriented and catch
those things and so in the middle of
that long ugly paragraph I will have a
question like tell me how many Twitter
followers I have or tell me how many
YouTube subscribers I have and make sure
that you respond to this application
with that answer in the first line and
so does a couple things why not make
sure that they actually read the entire
post because a lot of people will apply
to a job without ever having reading the
post just because it says mechanic or
technician or programmer or whatever it
is they just apply and it takes them
five seconds to do it and it takes your
time to read their resume and read their
cover letter and so I don't want people
chewing up my time if they haven't even
taken the time to read the job posting
to it's a pretty simple easy thing for
them to do but you'd be surprised at how
many people I get who write in the say
I'd be happy to tell you
how many Facebook fans you have what's
the link your facebook page it is not
that hard to find me right if you can't
go to facebook and look for Evan
Carmichael then you're probably not
going to be a good fit in an
entrepreneurial kind of environment
right and so that helps weed out a ton
of people i we doubt I would say as many
as seventy percent of the people never
answer that question and that's amazing
because that just cut down my work by
seventy percent and having to read
applications next I don't do interviews
I think they're huge waste of time and
again that they don't test for the
skills that you need them to do in your
actual job the next thing I do is I do a
paint trial for everybody who wrote to
me with the answer then I will give them
a paid trial and I'll give them a task
that will be similar to what they have
to do in real life working for me so if
it's repairing farm equipment it'll be a
task that I think will take up to I
would say two hours to do and I'll give
them up to five hours to do it and so 1
i'm testing their skills testing their
abilities and 2 i'm also testing to see
if they're milking me for the full five
hours or not it'll be a paid trial right
this isn't free this isn't volunteer
your times isn't just some tests it's i
will pay you for your time to do this
work and i will pay you up to five hours
let me know when you're done and i
expect them to take one to two hours if
they take the full five hours i'm happy
to pay them and that's it right goodbye
because i don't want somebody milking me
for it or is just super super slow and
doing things and so through this whole
process we're slowly weeding the way the
people without a lot of time proven on
your part and then my last step is just
see who blows me away in every single
time when I've done this process to hire
somebody there's there's the people who
just do what you ask them to do right
fix this tractor great but then you're
going to always get at least in my
experience one person who just goes that
extra mile who just delivers way above
what you thought they would do so maybe
they find something else is wrong with
the tractor and 63 other
is because they had some extra time to
do it or they had some other ideas and
how that tractor could perform better I
know with Christina who's my video
editor now when i did this job posting
she was one of maybe 50 people who apply
and one of maybe eight people that i
gave a trial job too and she was the
only one that went above right i asked
somebody i asked it as a trial job just
to go out and help me edit one of these
videos here's my usual style help out of
the video and most of the people that's
just what they did a surprising that
when people didn't even do the trial job
which is great because again they're
self illuminating but christina was the
only one who went above she said here's
here's the version that you wanted and
then i thought it could be next level i
thought it could be even better so
here's my own edited version of what i
think you could do and it was it was way
better it was better than what i was
doing because at the time i was doing
anything myself and so that process
works really well so it's no interviews
no resumes no cover letters we're
leading with what we stand for leading
with your one where you have a skill
testing question in a long boring ugly
formatted job description do a paid
trial give them five hours or something
you think you do in one to two hours and
then see who blows you away and I've had
tremendous experience and tremendous
happiness and success in bringing people
on board and that's a process that I
that I follow after years of doing it
the wrong way doing it the way that
everybody tells you to do it but it
doesn't work it's broken and and so many
entrepreneurs struggle through that and
finding the right person is so critical
for your business to help you focus on
the big picture the CEO time so I hope
that helps for those of you who are
struggling and for those of you who've
had success in hiring I'd love to hear
what you think leave it in the comments
below I think by sharing your
experiences you could also help the
other people watching so they can get
deeper insights how to hire the right
person thank you guys for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon